today we discussed two proposals to
strengthen the external borders and I'm
pleased to be able to announce today
that the council agreed that we have to
reinforce the checks at our external
borders so we adopted the measures and
the proposed changes in the code on that
issue we also continued our discussion
on European kosem border guard system
and we concluded that the agency should
serve three goals provide better
information about migration flows
identify the weak spots at our external
borders and respond swiftly to the
borders when they are at risk we have to
solve the migration crisis together
together with all Member States but also
together with all the countries along
the Balkan route and together with
Turkey and I understand that the high
influx puts countries under enormous
pressure and I also understand the urge
to take measures but those measures have
to be communicated and coordinated
better and we agreed today between all
the countries that from now on all
relevant countries have to be involved
on such matters measures are being taken
or further Titans in the next and days
we need tangible and clear results on
the ground otherwise there is a danger
that is a risk that the whole system
will completely break down the route
along the Western Balkans yes the
situation is very critical we have a
shared responsibility all of us towards
our neighboring states both EU and
non-eu but also towards those desperate
people we cannot continue with the wave
through policy the European Council was
crystal clear on that and we cannot put
caps or how many asylum seekers receive
this is simply not according to EU and
international rules to those who think
that we need national solutions because
a European approach is not working I say
it is precisely national actions that
are hindering a European approach